je pense aussi que raisonnablement on
pose tous le même diagnostic
le diagnostic c'est qu'on a un problème
d'indépendance technologique politique
et qu'on a un problème de feuille de
route sur la chaîne d'approvisionnement
numérique
quelle politique industrielle numérique
on pose de façon claire sur les trente
prochaines années
ce qu'a fait la chine en fait est en
effet à la rattraper son retard de façon
fulgurante avec une vision très claire
en concentrant ses fonds là où c'était
absolument stratégique pour elle et
l'autre chose aussi pour aller aussi
dans le sens de ce qui a été dit c'est
que en europe
aujourd'hui l'europe n'est pas un tout
l'europe les 27 pays aux intérêts
divergents et par rapport à macron sur
la question de l'autonomie stratégique
l'allemagne absolument pas du tout sur
la même ligne ni l'italie d'ailleurs
donc de toute façon cette phobie
américaine et franco française parce que
l'allemagne a à priori pas le même
niveau de problèmes avec son autonomie
stratégique à l
hormis sur la question de la défense et
encore et puis l'italie c'est encore
plus c'est encore plus neutre on va dire
comme rapport aux états unis à la
question de l'annulation d'un ténue
mairie donc c'est un débat qui est très
français donc de deux choses l'une soit
on rêve à une souveraineté dont
aujourd'hui on n'a pas les tenants et
aboutissants soit on se dit bas avec
l'existant avec ce qu'on a
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est ce
qu'on peut imaginer il se trouve qu'en
ce moment on a un alignement des
planètes avec bye donne donc pour des
raisons qui sont divergentes sans doute
mais il ya un chemin là pour penser des
choses et là où je suis d'accord aussi
c'est que en effet la question des
données de santé
on va avoir une vision européenne qui
n'est absolument pas celle des états
unis
la question c'est pas de devenir des
clones la question c'est de trouver les
points de jonction entre administrations
par rapport à la gouvernance des gars va
et ce qui m'amène à mon dernier point
souveraineté et gouvernance ne sont pas
la même chose
[Musique]